pasamos ahora a las noticias de la salud
con más Romero salamar Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela hoy con un
estudio interesantísimo que nos cuenta
sobre la evolución genética de los
pueblos indígenas del Amazonas de qué se
trata sí es un estudio publicado en
Science recientemente que muestra que la
selección natural a través de los siglos
y los siglos habría beneficiado a unas
personas que tenían una mutación
genética que los protege mejor contra la
enfermedad del chagas es la primera
evidencia en las Américas de una
evolución no provocada por un patógeno
provocada por una enfermedad se sabe que
el chagas que es esta enfermedad
provocada por un parásito estaba
presente en el continente americano
antes de la colonización porque se han
encontrado momias en Chile Brasil en
Perú de hace 7.000 y 9.000 años entonces
eso corresponde un poco con el estudio
que dice que esa diferenciación genética
no habría empezado hace
7.500 años en la investigación hallaron
tres genes diferenciados el ppp 3ca
desde el principal asociado la respuesta
inmune contra esta enfermedad
superponemos la zona de más prevalencia
de esa mutación genética con la zona de
más prevalencia del chagas vemos que
apenas se tocan es decir que la Cuenca
del Amazonas está protegida digamos o
despejada de esta enfermedad
principalmente O podría ser una de las
hipótesis porque su población tiene esta
mutación en genética que los protegen
mientras que muchas de las zonas andinas
donde hay muchísima prevalencia del
chagas parece que estas poblaciones Así
fueran las autóctonas Así fueran las
indígenas andinas no tienen esta
diferenciación genética que los protege
como ayuda esta mutación genética a
proteger contra el chagas pues sabemos
que el chagas está provocado por un
parásito que se llama tripanosoma cruz y
además de provocar lesiones cutáneas que
es por donde sucede la infección tiene
varias afectaciones en el corazón y en
el sistema cardiovascular y también
Sabemos que esta mutación tiene que ver
precisamente con la respuesta inmune y
que también está activa en definir el
tejido del corazón entonces del grupo de
investigación del estudio lo que hizo
fue el cultivo de células unos sin
la mutación unos con la mutación y Pues
exponerlos a este parásito después de 24
horas a la vemos la barra negra que son
las células que no tenían mutación la
barra roja las que sí tenían la mutación
en la barra roja decides decir las
células que tenían este Gen diferenciado
la presencia de parásitos era un 25%
menos todavía hace falta más
investigación dicen los mismos
científicos para entender el mecanismo
Exacto pero pues aquí se empiezan a dar
estas primeras pistas Bueno más la
enfermedad del chagas se considera una
enfermedad de Tropical desatendida sí
forma parte de una agrupación de
enfermedades que no se investigan a
pesar de afectar a millones de personas
especialmente en comunidades Ya de por
sí en empobrecidas no se transmite por
chinches que como decíamos generan estas
lesiones cutáneas puede generar también
fiebre náuseas o dolores de cabeza pero
es que además entre el 70 y el 80% de
las personas que se infectan serán
asintomáticas toda su vida en cambio hay
unas cuantas que tendrán implicaciones
graves en el corazón y neurológicas
entonces Bueno todavía no se ha
esclarecido por qué pero quizás saber
este estudio tener estas pistas ayude en
el continente americano rápidamente unas
cifras es endémico en 21 países afecta a
6 millones de personas hoy en día cada
año hay 30.000 contagios y 12.000
muertes anuales y bien hablemos ahora de
un último punto mar que tenemos algo de
tiempo sobre la desigualdad que existe
alrededor de esta enfermedad hay vacunas
o tratamientos no hay vacunas Sí hay
tratamientos pero el problema es que las
personas contagiadas lleguen a acceder a
estos tratamientos se calcula que solo
el 10% de casos del chagas son
diagnosticados y de esto Solo un 1%
accede realmente a los tratamientos algo
que es muy frustrante Porque además son
efectivos prácticamente en un 100% y
evitan todas estas grandes consecuencias
a largo plazo si se administran temprano
no es una cifra que muestra claramente
como la enfermedad pues afecta
comunidades empobrecidas que ayuda
además a cronificar la propia la propia
pobreza y por eso pues al final este
estudio junta dos cosas que no se
investigan nada que es una enfermedad
Como el chagas Y pues la genética o las
características de las poblaciones
indígenas Y así pues bueno es la primera
piedra también para ir adelantando ir
teniendo más conocimiento que al final
es la solución a muchas de estas
dolencias pues madre Muchísimas gracias
por traernos este nuevo estudio y nos
vemos mañana Gracias Ángel hasta mañana